Eddie before you go we need help with
our homework here there's a maths
problem that has left the entire
internet stumped can you help us solve
this
I'm just going to anticipate that there
are a few different opinions for people
who are maybe watching at home or maybe
even there in the studio with you lots
of people are thinking maybe it's uh two
times one plus two is six so six divided
by 6 gives you one which I think is what
you mentioned but other people are going
to argue and say no no hold up 6 divided
by two that's three and then you
multiply that by one plus two which is
three yes you get nine so is the answer
one or nine and you might hate me for a
second but I'm going to say the answer
is
yes
this is actually a mathematical equation
that get me right it was designed to be
ambiguous you might not like that but
it's a bit of a gotcha kind of problem
it's meant to trick you it's a
mathematical sentence a little bit like
I saw a man with a telescope now you
tell me did you see a man walking by and
he was holding a telescope in his hand
or did you look through a telescope and
see a man I saw a man with a telescope
is ambiguous and maths can be like that
sometimes too so one or nine they're
kind of both the answer oh Eddie we love
chatting with you thank you so much for
your time tonight